- Like the rest of the
world at this moment,
I'm obsessed with Dua Lipa.
All right, she was, I mean, she's awesome,
so that's why.
She was a battle round adviser
on The Voice last season
for team Kelly as well.
So she has great taste,
let's start with that
and she couldn't have been nicer.
It's always nice to like meet
people you adore musically
and then they live up to
your expectations as a human
in real life.
But the other day she
had a big announcement.
It was so secret in fact,
she called me before the audience
got into the house seats at our studio.
So they couldn't hear yet either
and we can finally share
what she had to say.
So check it out.
Hey, what's up, Dua?
How you doing?
Where are you?
- I'm good, I'm in London.
It's nice to see you, how are you?
- I'm good actually, I'm great.
Life is getting so much better, right?
So before, before I forget though,
thank you so much for helping
team Kelly on The Voice.
Did you have fun?
You were so good at it.
- Oh, thank you, I had so much fun.
It was definitely such a new experience,
but it was so cool to
get to learn next to you
and see the way that you mentor everyone
was really amazing and
super inspiring, I loved it.
- Oh man well, ditto,
you have such a great energy
about you, you're such a light.
It was so fun and I
love your music so much.
It was just, it was cool to
like love someone musically
and then you lived up like as a human.
(laughing)
Like sometimes
it doesn't always happen.
- Thank you.
- Well, you have an announcement
about your upcoming concert Studio 2054
so first what's happening at this concert?
- So it's an exclusive live performance,
but because I had to now
postpone my tour twice now,
I decided to do an online performance,
something that although
we can't all be together,
something that kind of
brings the party to you
and in that sense, I just wanted to create
a really unique experience,
build all these crazy sets,
something that I wouldn't
be able to do on tour
and just have some fun
and have that, you know,
I've been missing so much
that human connection
and so it's, I think it's
gonna be nice to kind of
bring everyone together
in terms of the dancers
and the band and create a real fun,
you know, moment with
lots of guest appearances
and guest performers.
and it'll be fun, I'm excited.
I'm really looking forward to it.
- I am so excited to see
this, I'm not kidding.
I think we're all craving like
any form of live performance
or, you know, I think we all
need that like right now.
So I'm, it's the coolest idea.
I'm so excited you're
doing it, but you today,
you're finally able to share
one of the big names, right?
That's gonna be a guest.
- Yeah, I'm really,
really excited to announce
that Miley Cyrus will
be joining me for this.
- Oh my--
- She'll be
one of the many special
guests I'm gonna have,
but she's a very, very,
very special guest.
I'm so excited to have her.
- Oh my gosh, that's so exciting,
I'm loving her whole new look.
She's like doing the
whole John Jett thing,
I'm loving her whole new vibe, right now.
- I know, she's sinister.
- Yeah, she's like a little chameleon
every time she comes out new album,
I love how her vibe always changes
and her style and she pulls it off.
That's gonna be so fun.
I cannot wait to see that.
It was nice to talk with you.
I'm such a fan of you,
will you come by soon?
- Thank you so much,
Thank you for your time,
I've loved talking to you.
Hopefully I'll see you again soon.
- All right, bye Dua Lipa!
Have a good one.
- Bye, thanks.
- All right y'all,
tickets are on sale for
Dua Lipa's virtual concert
Studio 2054.
You do not want to miss it.
It streams November 27th on Live Now,
it's gonna be amazing.